[Música]
estas son las noticias de France 24 la
OMS hace un llamado a restringir las
celebraciones de Navidad y de año nuevo
ante el aumento de casos de covid-19
debido a la variante Omicron el director
del organismo tedros adhanom ghebreyesus
se pidió a los gobiernos tomar medidas
así estás no sean populares todo sea
posible para mitigar el impacto del
nuevo repunte de contagios
el primer ministro del Reino Unido por
el Johnson quién fue fotografiado junto
a su esposa y 17 personas más en un
encuentro está en medio de un escándalo
allí en el encuentro no respetaron las
medidas de bioseguridad cuando aumentan
precisamente los casos de covid-19
debido a la variante o micro en el Reino
Unido y se le ha sugerido a los
ciudadanos restringir los encuentros
familiares y también los valen las
escuelas y los restaurantes permanecen
cerrados
el presidente electo de Chile Gabriel
Boric se reúne a esta hora o se reunió
con el presidente Sebastián Piñera en el
Palacio de La Moneda para dar inicio al
proceso de traspaso de poder Boris busco
consenso en el centro y en la izquierda
para establecer un sistema de bienestar
similar al que hay en los países
europeos
muy buenas tardes bienvenidos a las
noticias de France 24 soy Santiago López
González gracias por estar con nosotros
hasta ahora el director general de la
OMS tedros adhanom ghebreyesus han
recomendado cancelar los eventos
planeados para las fiestas de Navidad y
de año nuevo ante el aumento de los
casos de contagio de covid 19 a nivel
mundial en una conferencia de prensa en
Ginebra en Suiza el director general
aseguro que la variante Omicron puede
ser contraida por personas que ya
cuentan con el esquema completo de
vacunación o que ya se infectaron de
covid-19 en el pasado Pedro hizo tomar
conciencia frente a esta situación ante
las festividades de fin de año y también
insto a los gobiernos a tomar decisiones
así estás no sean populares
queremos volver a la normalidad
difíciles que deben tomarse para
protegernos a nosotros mismos y a los
demás en algunos casos eso significará
cancelar o retrasar eventos al igual que
hemos tenido que cancelar la recepción
que planeamos tener hoy pero un evento
cancelado es mejor que una vida
cancelada que es mejor cancelar ahora y
celebrar más tarde que celebrar ahora y
llorar más tarde ninguno de nosotros
quiere volver a estar aquí dentro de 12
meses
you know escándalo afectado al primer
ministro británico Boris Johnson a quien
en una fotografía publicada por el
diario The Guardian se lo ve junto a su
esposa y a 17 personas más en el jardín
de Downing Street la residencia oficial
según el portavoz de Johnson se trataba
de una reunión de trabajo pero los
asistentes no respetaron el
distanciamiento social y estaban tomando
vino y comiendo queso la imagen toma
relevancia en momentos en que aún están
cerrados los colegios los bares y los
restaurantes en todo el Reino Unido y se
sugirió también a los británicos evitar
las reuniones familiares y las
aglomeraciones entre otras restricciones
todo esto ante el rápido avance de
contagio en ese país por covid-19 debido
a la variante en Omicron el primer
ministro se refirió a este tema
escuchemos
pues incendio bueno para ser justos no
vivo en el lugar de trabajo donde
trabajo entonces el número 10 de Downing
Street y el jardín es usado para
trabajar y fue usado durante esa semana
creo que el primer ministro se ve allí
justo después de la conferencia de
prensa que había hecho las personas en
casa recordarán las ruedas de prensa
diarias y las reuniones que el tubo
antes creo con el secretario de Salud
más temprano en el día o en la semana
como pueden ver ahí ahí empleados porque
fundamentalmente es un lugar de trabajo
mentirosa y seguimos en Europa la Emma
la Agencia Europea del Medicamento
respaldo el uso de la vacuna
estadounidense novavax desde principio
proteinico para combatir el covid-19
novavax sería entonces la quinta vacuna
en superar este filtro por parte de las
autoridades médicas europeas y en la
primera vacuna basada en proteínas
recomendada para combatir el covid-19 y
mayores de 18 años la Unión Europea
también indico que va a apoyar las
campañas de vacunación en los estados y
acordó una compra de lotes de vacunas
entre los 27 países que conforman la
Unión Europea para hacer frente al
repunte de casos debido a la variante o
micro
los resultados de los estudios muestran
una eficacia de la vacuna para subir de
alrededor de 90% la SEP original del
shark 2 y alguno de variantes
preocupantes como alfa y beta fueron las
más comunes que circulaban cuando los
estudios estuvieron en curso actualmente
existen datos limitados sobre la
eficacia de Nueva HB frente a otras
variantes de interés incluido o m en el
Palacio de La Moneda en Santiago sede
del Poder Ejecutivo de Chile se
reunieron el primer el primer encuentro
a puerta cerrada del presidente saliente
Sebastián Piñera y el presidente electo
Gabriel Boric de esta manera se pone en
marcha así el proceso de traspaso de
poder durante su campaña Boriken es un
ex líder estudiantil buscaoposiciones de
centro para sumar votos más allá de los
jóvenes que salieron a las calles
durante el estallido social del 2019
también prometió la creación de un
sistema de bienestar similar al que hay
en Europa que garantiza salud y
educación Luis Muñoz nos presenta file
del presidente electo por los chilenos
Gabriel Boric a sus 35 años es el
presidente más joven de la historia de
Chile
un discurso que busco a los jóvenes que
participaron en el estallido social de
2019 en rebeldía contra el conocido como
milagro económico de Chile
precisamente Boris se dio a conocer como
líder estudiantil en 2011 esto le
permitió saltar a la política en 2014
cuándo fue escogido diputado de
Magallanes la zona más Australia
olvidada de Chile de dónde es oriundo
su partido Convergencia social forma
parte de la coalición Frente Amplio
junto al Partido Comunista se convierte
ahora en el presidente más a la
izquierda en Chile desde Salvador
Allende derrocado por un golpe de Estado
en 1973 Boris buscar enterrar a la
dictadura militar de Augusto Pinochet y
su Constitución de 1980 representando a
una nueva generación que ha dejado atrás
la histórica centroizquierda de la
Concertación e incluso su última
Presidenta Michelle Bachelet pidió votar
por Boris
entonces por qué candidatos se vota
una búsqueda de centro que se sumó a sus
críticas a los gobiernos de Venezuela y
Nicaragua pero desde la oposición no se
fía ni condena en su reunión en España
con uno de los asesinos del diputado
derechista Jaime Guzmán Boris promete
diálogo y recuerda el 15 de noviembre de
2019 cuándo fue artífice del acuerdo que
derribo en el actual proceso
constituyente esto le valió críticas
internas en su coalición mientras sin
corbata y arremangado has logrado ser el
presidente de la nueva Constitución
en otros temas la estrella del tenis
chino Peng Shuai negó haber sido
agredida sexualmente por un alto
dirigente del Partido Comunista Chino y
declaro que vive libremente los
comentarios los hizo en su primera
entrevista a un medio de comunicación
desde que sus acusaciones desataron la
preocupación internacional por su
seguridad sin embargo las declaraciones
no aliviaron las dudas y los
cuestionamientos por parte de la
Asociación de tenis femenino
fue entrevistada en un acto promocional
en Shanghai para los Juegos Olímpicos de
Invierno de Pekín aparecido junto a la
ex estrella de la NBA Yao Ming cuando un
periodista de Singapur le pregunto ella
negó haber sido agredida sexualmente
ante todo debo subrayar que nunca he
dicho ni escrito nada acusando a nadie
de haberme agredido sexualmente ese es
un punto muy importante eso contradice
su denuncia del 2 de noviembre las redes
sociales de que el ex primer ministro
chino Shang ha olido la había obligado a
mantener relaciones sexuales en varias
ocasiones tras esta acusación la ex
campeona de dobles de Wimbledon y el
Abierto de Francia desapareció de la
vida pública hasta esta sesión de firma
de autógrafos el 21 de noviembre lo que
pone en duda su libertad de movimiento y
su seguridad la preocupación se extendió
por todo el mundo incluyendo la ONU la
Casa Blanca y otras estrellas del tenis
la Asociación Femenina de la bicicleta
ha reaccionado y domingo a su
declaración seguimos pidiendo una
investigación completa justa y
transparente sin censura sobre su
acusación de agresión sexual la
Asociación de tenis femenino ha
suspendido todos los torneos en China
incluido Hong Kong ante la preocupación
por Pen helecho alimento las peticiones
de boicot a los Juegos de Pekín el
Ministerio de Asuntos Exteriores chino
ha dicho que el caso se exagero
maliciosamente
ya través de su cuenta en Twitter el
tenista español Rafael Nadal anuncio que
ha dado positivo por covid-19 el
deportista hizo pública su condición a
su regreso a España tras un torneo de
exhibición que lo llevo por los Emiratos
Árabes y Kuwait donde reapareció después
de más de 4 meses sin hacer la aparición
y deportivas o públicas nada le indicó
que se siente bien
y así llegamos al final de las noticias
en France 24 siga con nosotros buenas
tardes
[Música]